la france s'installe dans les grèves des
grèves qui s'étend se durcissent et se
politise nous allons y revenir à l'issue
d'une réunion à matignon et tous les
ministres concernés a été décidé la mise
en place de moyens de transport de
substitution en ile de france environ 15
100 car privés vont être mis en place
progressivement et les bateaux mouches
seront gratuits en fin d'après midi
reportage laurent bailly fredrik fort
cet après midi les responsables de la
sncf de la ratp et surtout les
représentants des compagnies d'autocars
privés ont donc rencontré bernard pons
et anne marie idrac les responsables
gouvernementaux des transports objectif
pallier la paralysie totale demain
encore des transports en commun en ile
de france
nous avons donc décidé avec le syndicat
des transports en région ile de france
de mettre en place un système de
dépannage un système d'assistance qui
bien entendu sur un modeste par rapport
à l'ampleur du problème
modeste parce que les 1700 autres cars
affrétés ne pourront véhicule et que
cent mille personnes au lieu des 800
milles qui voyagent habituellement aux
heures de pointe
il en coûtera 3 millions de francs par
jour à l'étape mais ce sera gratuit pour
les usagers
concrètement à partir de mardi matin 140
lignes de substitution seront installés
au départ des grandes villes de la
banlieue parisienne de 5h30 à 6h30
l'écart convergeront vers 13
destinations dans paris même trajet en
sens inverse entre 16 et 17 heures dès
demain dans paris encore des vedettes et
divers bateaux mouches circuleront
toutes les 20 minutes environ sur la
seine entre bercy et la maison de la
radio
ces navettes fluviales ne seront en
service comme les autocars qu'à partir
de demain après midi enfin selon nos
informations si la grève devait se
prolonger quelques temps encore la ratp
pourrait sur présentation de la carte
orange 2 décembre accorder la gratuité
du transport pour janvier 96